we move on the gunman behind new
zealand's worst mass shooting has been
sentenced to life in prison without the
chance of
parole brenton tarrant killed 51 muslim
worshipers in christchurch last year the
relatives of some of his victims spoke
outside court just a short time ago
they say they're pleased that justice
has been served
today
the legal procedures for this heinous
crime
has been done no punishment
will bring our loved ones back
we respect our justice system
and the new zealand muslim community
and the non-muslim as well
we stood together against hate and we
set
our own model for the wall
al jazeera's correspondent wayne haye
covered the shooting extensively for us
here on this channel he joins us live
now from
bangkok so wayne just talk us through
the sentencing
and what's happening today
yes well i think certainly a lot of
relief a lot of emotion
will be pouring out in the hours ahead
following that sentencing
in the high court in christchurch the
city where that
awful attack took place in march last
year the sentencing itself came on the
fourth day of this process
the first three days were very emotional
harrowing accounts given by
survivors of the of the attack also
family members
of victims going through exactly what
happened
to them addressing brenton tarrant
directly looking at him
in the eye and on the fourth day that
emotion continued when
eventually the judge gave his sentence
it was a very long
sentencing he spoke for around two hours
uh detailing exactly what he thought
about brenton tarrant and his actions he
called
called him wicked uh and inhuman and
certainly cast a lot of skepticism over
his comments previously before the
sentencing
to psychologists etc that he'd given up
his beliefs in the
white supremacy ideology that apparently
drove him
uh to commit these attacks the judge
expressing a lot of skepticism
that he had changed his mind well let's
have a look back now
at that tragic day in march last year
at just after 1 40 in the afternoon on
the 15th of march last year
emergency services received the first
calls
a shooting was underway during friday
prayers at the al-noor mosque in central
christchurch
i saw one gun in the floor
and police was stopping here there was a
lot of people died
injured in total 44 worshipers were
killed by brenton tarrant at el nor
in an attack he live streamed on the
internet he then moved on to his second
target across town
the linwood mosque where he killed a
further seven people
the youngest victim just three years old
the eldest
77. he was arrested by police as he was
making his way to a third mosque in a
town nearby
it is clear that this can now only be
described
as a terrorist attack that was
determined because of the pre-planned
nature of the attack
and the ideology tarrant subscribed to
the australian had studied the layout of
the mosques
and their busiest times he'd uploaded a
manifesto detailing his white supremacy
beliefs
and his hatred of muslims and
non-european immigrants
as the wider population rallied around
the new zealand muslim community
attention turned to the high-powered
weapons he fired
how he obtained them and in some cases
modified them legally
i can tell you one thing right now our
gun laws
will change less than a month later most
semi-automatic weapons became illegal
and a government buyback scheme for guns
began
in march this year tarrant surprised
prosecutors by entering a guilty plea
that meant there'd be no trial but the
judge wanted some of the 40 survivors
and family members of those killed
to have the opportunity to speak
directly to the gunman in court
more than 60 statements were given
during the sentencing
he had no issue with linda armstrong
he didn't even know her
instead filled with his own racist
agenda
this coward hid behind his
big powerful guns and shot little old
linda from afar
she never even stood a chance
he took something away from me the
sentencing of brent and tarrant may help
provide some closure and healing
but his hatred and terror changed the
lives of so many
and one of new zealand's darkest days
will never be forgotten
well certainly a very difficult
emotional uh four days coming to an
end for those people who were present in
the courtroom giving
those statements but the sentence handed
down by the judge in the christchurch
high court
will no doubt be welcomed by them it was
a historic sentence
never before in new zealand has a
sentence of life
without the opportunity of parole being
handed down so it was really as far as
the judge could go
uh as difficult as it was for the
survivors and family members
of the victims to be in court to deliver
uh those statements
it was something i think as of a
cathartic exercise as well
initially as mentioned uh the list of
statements was around 60
that increased to 90 in the end as more
people wanted to have their say
more people wanted to look at brenton
tarrant to speak directly to him
in court and they took courage from what
others were
saying in court so again no doubt the
sentence
of life without parole for brent and
tarrant the man who killed 51 people in
march last year
will be welcomed by all concerned
wayne many thanks